well first I was kind of scared because
he never spoke he didn't say any he
didn't say anything in the first meeting
when we met each other do you understand
the word
the word a jacket didn't say nothing the
whole time he was just like shaking his
head first time I met him and he just
keep talking I just look at that guy why
why he keep talking
and I thought I pulled the director
decide after me I said does he speak
English man we there's no way we can do
this move if he don't speak English man
I gotta have him communicate with me and
he's so fast he said don't worry he's
just checking you out he's checking you
out that's what they do just he's
Chinese
understand the words that are coming out
of my mouth that was the whole thing I
came up with do you understand the words
that are coming out of my mouth because
I was like the first time I met her I
was like do you understand English
doesn't speak English don't know
numbers that are coming out of your
mouth man